we begin this morning with two new
policy pushes expected from the Trump
administration over the next few days as
mr. Trump approaches his first 100 days
in office it appears there is a rush to
make good on to camp a key campaign
promises health care and taxes the
president announcing quote massive tax
cuts should be ready by Wednesday and
that health care won't be too far behind
Errol Barnett is at the White House with
the latest Errol good morning good
morning president Trump brushed aside
reporters questions on Friday as they
asked if there will be another attempt
to repeal Obamacare in the coming days
president Trump said it doesn't matter
if Congress votes next week even though
he is rushing to add to his list of
accomplishments as we approach his 100th
day in office it's going to be great
president Trump is putting pressure on
Republican congressional leadership to
make another attempt to repeal Obamacare
next week Trump beamed about the
possibility Friday outside the Treasury
Department no particular rush but we
will see what happens but health care is
coming along well enthusiasm he first
stated thursday at a joint news
conference with the italian prime
minister this is a continuation and the
plan gets better and better and better
and it's gotten really really good and a
lot of people are liking it a lot we
have a good chance of getting it soon
because Congress has yet to see text of
a bill to estimate costs engage how it
might change insurance coverage it's
unclear if or when a vote will happen
still president Trump is sure lawmakers
will both address health care and agree
on a federal budget to avoid a
government shutdown next week okay i
want to get both are you shocked to hear
that as far as keeping the government
open i think we want to keep the
government open don't you agree in an
interview with The Associated Press
president Trump said businesses and
individuals will receive a quote massive
tax cut under a tax reform plan he will
unveil next week the president is
feeling pressure to deliver something
significant by next Saturday his 100th
day in office Trump tweeted his
frustration Friday no matter how much I
accomplished
during the ridiculous standard of the
first 100 days and it has been a lot
media will kill but the president
embraced the 100-day measurement as a
candidate with this contract with the
American voter which now reads like a
list of still yet to be delivered
achievements like repealing Obamacare
ending illegal immigration and passing
an affordable child care act a president
Trump is spending the weekend here in
Washington which means he has spent
exactly 7 weekends as president at this
location and the exact same number at
his morrow logo Resort in Florida but
the president is expected to switch
weekend getaway locations soon and
instead choose to go to his golf
property in New Jersey Alex Errol
Barnett at the White House thanks Errol